so scary about being an entrepreneur you
know the truth is Ally like I don't even
know how to fully answer that because I
don't that's like asking me what's the
best thing about being a human being or
what's the greatest part of breathing
oxygen right like you know I I mean the
best part for me is that I'm doing what
I think I naturally was born to do it
was kind of like what was the worst part
of my life between six and 18 years old
and that was I was forced to do school
in a world where that was like ripping
my eye directly out of my head right
like to me the best part is it's my
natural being it's Who I am and I love
entrepreneurship and meritocracy and
capitalism and market behaviors so much
I even like them more than my own
well-being
like I secretly think that if I deserve
to go out of business that that would
excite me because I think I deserve it
right like I love the game so much that
I am often you know for example right
now we're in a very political climate
and I'm yelling at all my old white dude
rich friends and our 60s and 70s who
think they're capitalists sell because
they want a Republican president to
protect their money and I'm like you're
goddamn loser because you you think that
just because you made the money you're
entitled to save it nobody nobody is
keeping IBM or Google or AT&T or BMW
alive that's the market and nobody
should keep an individual alive this is
capitalism this is business and you
should grind forever and if you if you
take the foot off the pedal in your 50s
60s 70s and 80s you should lose upside
you should use and so I just love the
game of business and entrepreneurship
and to me that excites me and that's the
best part
you